bonjour à tous vous avez pu le constater
comme nous pour ce dernier week-end de
juillet le temps a l'air de vouloir se
gâter sur une grande partie de la france
il ne faisait que 14 degrés ce matin à
paris dans le sud ouest il y à des
orages et beaucoup de vent et d'ailleurs
la chaleur et le vent ont provoqué
plusieurs incendies de forêt dans les
landes en montagne même
nombreux sont les alpinistes en
difficulté et c'est ainsi que sur
l'aiguillé du midi à 3600 mètres
d'altitude une cordée de deux français à
passer la nuit sous la grêle et la neige
et il a fallu qu'un hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie et dix sauveteurs se
dépenses pendant trois heures ce matin
pour les tirer de leur mauvaise
situation en les hissant sur le sommet
d'un python l'aiguillé du midi grâce à
un treuil car il ne pouvait plus bouger
du tout évidemment vous poser comme nous
la question est ce que cela va durer ce
mauvais temps et bien nous allons
essayer d'avoir une réponse grâce à un
spécialiste de la météorologie nationale
qui est avec nous aujourd'hui c'est
monsieur fond ce qui est ingénieur à la
météorologie nationale
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de
ce temps pour le week end à bord nous
allons tout d'abord voir la provision
qui est fait pour demain comme vous le
voyez nous avons amené une zone de pluie
assez mauvais temps du sud de la
bretagne au nord du bordelais et au
languedoc où naturellement les pluies
seront faibles mais continues ce qui
aura un caractère assez désagréable une
autre zone de temps assez médiocre c'est
celle qui s'étant pratiquement du nord
du cotentin au pratiquement presque à la
méditerranée où le temps sera très
nuageux et plus vraiment là peut-être
pratiquement ne prévoit pas de pluie
dans cette zone mais on verra pas
souvent le soleil
il reste maintenant les zones où il fait
relativement beau c'est à dire le sud du
bordelais où il y aura du soleil est
également le nord et les frontières de
l'est où il y aura également du soleil
maintenant en méditerranée très beau
temps malheureusement il y aura du
mistral encore et pour les températures
on prévoit un minimum un maximum pardon
de 28 degrés sur ces régions là 23
degrés sur une grande marque partie de
la france et 20 degrés ou
malheureusement le ciel sera très
nuageux à couvert avec des pluies
voilà c'est la zone en petit assuré sur
notre cas bon alors ça voilà la
situation
maintenant il faudrait c'est de savoir
que de comprendre pourquoi on en est
arrivé là qu'est ce qui se passe dans le
ciel ce qui se passe dans le ciel nous
allons le voir avec une carte datant la
carte
c'est assez simple ce qui se passe on a
matérialisé sur cette carte des zones
nuageuses qui arrive par l'ouest et qui
vont amener les pluies sur les régions
qu'ils ont eu tout à l'heure mais pour
l'heure ce qui nous intéresse encore
c'est l'air frais qui s'écoule du nord
de la scandinavie en direction de la
manche et qui a amené des orages cette
nuit et même une un passage pluvieux qui
s'éloigne heureusement dans l'est
maintenant temps toujours eu assez beau
sur l'espagne et sur le midi
méditerranéen avec mistral
voilà et est ce que le mauvais temps
doit durer longtemps et ce qu'il faudra
attendre pour voir revenir le soleil
pour l'instant ne sont pas très
optimistes en ce qui concerne le temps
parce qu'on vous l'avez vu il ya des
masses nuageuses qui arrivent et qui a
conquis sont accompagnées de pluie donc
je pense qu'on va avoir une semaine
relativement médiocre sur une grande
partie de la france
oui c'est d'autant plus ennuyeux que ce
week end marque aussi la première grande
rentrée des estivants de juillet
d'ailleurs si vous avez circuler un peu
autour de paris au cours des dernières
24 heures vous êtes rendu compte qu'il
était assez difficile de rouler en
direction de la capitale
donc si vous devez rentrer de vacances
pendant ce week-end un conseil suivez
attentivement les prescriptions des
services de gendarmerie et surtout
n'hésitez pas à emprunter certaines des
déviations même toutes les déviations
qui vous seront proposés en effet ces
déviations n'ont pas été choisis tracé
au hasard ça se fait très scientifique
mans grâce à l'électronique pour tout
dire avec un ordinateur d'un pc de
gendarmerie située en rase campagne
l'ordinateur qui a sous son contrôle
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
national interroge les postes de
surveillance automatique sans
l'intervention de quiconque
le capteur interrogé envoie ses réponses
toutes les deux minutes le cerveau
électronique fait ainsi le tour des
capteurs à ces informations toutes les
30 minutes
s'ajoutent les observations recueillies
par les gendarmes sur le bord de la
route et transmises par radio téléphone
longueur des files d'attentes présence
de poids lourds nombre de véhicules
heure et même météo
ces observations sont confiés
l'ordinateur qui les absorbe les
analyses les digère et ordonne à 15 km
20 ou 80 le flot des véhicules et des
tournées grâce à sa vision d'une
importante fraction du réseau routier
l'ordinateur peut prévoir avec plusieurs
heures d'avancé le bouchon qui
inévitablement se formera si rien n'est
fait à 140 kilomètres avant ce lieu
supposé les voitures seront envoyés sur
une dérivation et trouveront devant tel
le champ libre
le tweet faire confiance au conseil du
cerveau électronique 40 conducteurs
devant nous obéirons sur 92
mais les 52 désobéissants se seront
heurtés à un bouchon de plus en plus
l'exploitant souhaite posséder une
influence qu'une signalisation qui
soient influencés par les facteurs
aléatoires tels que formation de
brouillard formation de verglas
le bouchon chutes de pluie etc et que le
caractère figé des panneaux actuels ne
peuvent pas suffisamment en compte si
vous voulez un exemple le panneau de
verglas s'il est inanimé et s'il reste
en permanence sur la route finira par ne
plus être observés en ag car s'il de
voir plein mois de juillet c'est bien
verglas possible et quand il reverra le
même à la même place
en hiver les bien entendu ne retiendra
aucun compte
aussi comment sans introduire dans la
signalisation des paramètres tels que
nombre de véhicules vitesse moyenne état
de la chaussée débit concentration etc
qui permettent de faire varier cette
signalisation suivant le jour l'heure et
les conditions atmosphériques ans ce
directeur d'une société d'électronique
le portique automatique finalement ne
fait que remplacer le produit gendarmes
c'est une utilisation primaire de
l'ordinateur il faut aller plus loin de
la voie en fonction des heures de la
journée
eh bien nous étudions quels sont les
pointes de trafic à certaines heures de
la journée pour fêter
nous commençons par invité avec crayons
2009 la valeur minimum que nous nous
fixons et ensuite la valeur maximum est
ensuite automatiquement en pointant
simplement est différente crêpes
nous voyons quelle heure de la journée
de ses calculs on a déterminé que la
vitesse optimale pour faire écouler le
plus grand nombre de véhicules se situer
entre 50 et 60 km heure au dessous on
piétine au dessus la distance entre
chaque véhicule s'accroît on vient donc
de mettre au point un panneau
électromagnétiques multi indications
télécommandé par un ordinateur qui
affichera les vitesses conseiller en
fonction de l'intensité de la
circulation
ce n'est qu'un début le problème est de
rendre aux panneaux leur valeur
d'information
ce sera vrai lorsque leurs indications
changeront en même temps qui évolue la
situation la direction donnée aux
recherches
dans les affaires politiques ce sont
encore les dernières déclarations du
président égyptien nasser qui font la
une des journaux vous savez
qu'avant-hier nasser a annoncé qu'il
acceptait le plan de paix américain du
secrétaire d'état william rogers plan de
paix qui prévoit notamment un cessez le
feu réel de 90 jours c'est-à-dire de
trois mois dès hier les habitués des
affaires du moyen-orient se demandait ce
que cachait au fond cette déclaration de
nasser quelles étaient ses intentions
véritables et bien nasser lui-même a
précisé sa pensée
dès la nuit dernière au cours d'une
nouvelle réunion et voici ce qu'il en
est c'est en effet devant le congrès de
l'union socialiste arabe que le
président nasser a justifié la réponse
de son gouvernement au plan de paix
américain
c'est une acceptation sans conditions ni
réserve pour les égyptiens qui ont
conscience que le plan rogers c'est le
plan de la dernière chance
il s'agit avant tout d'empêcher
qu'israël ne se présente à l'opinion
publique mondiale comme un martyr
l'egypte ne se fait cependant pas trop
d'illusions sur le succès de ce plan
elle attend les réactions américaine et
la réponse d'israël
parlant du cessez-le-feu le chef de
l'état égyptien a précisé que toute
violation du cessez le feu avec la syrie
et la jordanie serait considérée par le
caire comme une violation du
cessez-le-feu avec la ra eu car nous
sommes liés à ces pays parlait et et de
défense enfin le président nasser devait
déclarer à propos des pilotes israéliens
détenus en egypte ils ne rendront plus
les pilotes capturé par nos forces car
il est plus important pour nous de
garder ses pilotes plutôt que de
détruire leur fonte
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que les
réactions arabes sont dans l'ensemble
défavorable
le président nasser l'avait prévu il y
aura certainement des surenchères une
contre propagande et une campagne de
dénigrement d'avs et il déclare cette
préoccupation était sans doute partagé
par monsieur mahmoud ryad
car la veille le ministre égyptien des
affaires étrangères avait réuni vous les
voyez en ce moment sur ces images les
chefs des missions diplomatiques arabes
représentait au caire pour leur faire
part de la réponse égyptienne au plan
rogers
oui il est certain que l'acceptation du
plan rogers par le président nasser
était assez mal accueillis dans un
certain nombre de pays arabes en irak en
particulier le quotidien officiel du
gouvernement qui s'appelle al
joumhouriya écrit ce matin l'irak
affirme son refus absolu d'accepter les
propositions de paix américaine la seule
voie qui peut mener à la victoire c'est
la lutte armée il faut jeter le plan
rogers 11 la lave dans la boîte aux
ordures de l'histoire les unes après les
autres les divers organisations
palestiniennes font la même chose
c'est-à-dire elle critique nasser est
acceptée dans la hâte les propositions
américaines c'est rendre service à ceux
qui luttent contre nous dit par exemple
fdp lp qui est la troisième organisation
palestinienne par ordre d'importance
un chef d'état arabe cependant est
particulièrement embarrassés c'est
hussein de jordanie
il a reçu hier un message de nasser qui
essaie de le convaincre de dire oui à
son tour au plan rogers mais s'il
accepte les propositions américaines
hussein de jordanie ne risque-t-il pas
de se trouver devant une nouvelle deux
épreuves de force avec les commandos
palestiniens
et bien c'est possible et on comprend
donc qu'il hésite le gouvernement
jordanien s'est réuni hier pendant plus
de quatre heures il doit se réunir de
nouveau aujourd'hui mais on attend
toujours sa réponse comme on attend
d'ailleurs celle du gouvernement
israélien
athènes deuxième journée aujourd'hui des
deux palestiniens auteurs de l'attentât
contre le bureau de la compagnie et la
halle à athènes au mois de novembre
dernier au cours de cet attentat
il y as dergarabedian et mansur mourad
avait tué un enfant greg de deux ans et
demi et c'est la déposition du père de
cet enfant qui a marqué hier la première
journée du procès monsieur christophe
nas tous le père du petit garçon a
traité les accusés d' assassin ils ont
tué mon enfant at il dit mon second fils
n'a pas encore pu être opéré des 54
éclats de grenade et de bois de
l'explosif lui a planté dans le corps
jusque dans l'oeil
en quittant la barre monsieur nast
hausse a tenté de frapper les accusés et
les menaçant je vous retrouverai je vous
tuerai canton deux palestiniens rendu
confiant par la boue promesses du
gouvernement grec de les libérer quel
que soit le verdict du procès ils ont
réaffirmé qu'ils
vais pas eu l'intention de tuer mais
seulement de faire du bruit il y as
dergarabedian que vous voyez à gauche et
qui a reconnu avoir lancé la grenade a
exprimé ses regrets et demandé pardon au
peuple grec
le gouvernement grec a confirmé
officiellement hier qu'ils tiendraient
la promesse faite du mercredi sur
l'aéroport d'athènes aux pirates qui
avaient capturé un avion d olympic
airways
ils remettront bien à la croix-rouge
dergarabedian et son complice le mois
prochain
première journée aussi d'un autre procès
s'est éteint hier à los angeles celui de
charles manson et de trois de ses
adeptes de sa secte c'est à dire des
assassins de sharon tate l'actrice
américaine et de quatre de ses amis
manson est arrivé dans la salle
d'audience avec une cicatrice en forme
de x sur le front des cicatrices qu'il
s'était faite avec une lame de rasoir ou
s'est il procuré cette lame
mystère je me suis fait cette marque
pour montrer que je suis exclu de votre
monde at il dit simplement aux
journalistes pendant que ses complices
pénétrait à leur tour dans la salle
d'audience
la première séance était consacrée à la
lecture de l'acte d'accusation dressé
par le procureur vincent bugliosi le
voici la thèse de l'accusation est la
suivante manson est une sorte de fou un
mégalomane qui se prend à la fois pour
satan et pour le christ qui a autant de
haine pour les noirs que pour les blancs
et qui va chercher son inspiration dans
certaines chansons des beatles il a tué
sharon tate et ses amis c'était pour
déclencher une guerre civile entre les
blancs et les noirs car ils pensaient
que ce massacre serait mis sur le compte
des noirs et après quoi
une fois la guerre civile terminée et
bien manson et sa secte qui pendant ce
temps là sont restés réfugiés dans le
désert
manson et sa secte aurait été appelé au
pouvoir c'est une thèse qui n'est pas
simple c'est celle du procureur
n'oublions zee on pourra même dire
qu'elle est peut-être un peu tortueuses
mais qu'est ce qui n'est pas tortueux
dans cette sombre affaire
la grande bretagne a un nouveau ministre
des finances depuis ce matin c'est
monsieur anthony barber le voici il
était jusqu'à présent chargé des
questions européennes il succède à
monsieur ian mcleod qui a succombé à une
crise cardiaque
au début de la semaine les six ministres
du marché commun qui négocie avec la
grande-bretagne trouvera donc maintenant
devant eux un nouvel interlocuteur à la
place de monsieur barbu mais ce nouvel
interlocuteur
n'est pas encore désigne en france
monsieur olivier guichard le ministre de
l'éducation nationale vient de répondre
par lettre aux présidents des nouvelles
universités parisiennes qui s'inquiétait
du manque de moyens financiers mis à
leur disposition pour la prochaine
rentrée
monsieur richard leur fait savoir qu'ils
ne pourront pas compter sur de nouveaux
crédits il leur recommande de veiller à
la meilleure organisation possible de
leurs universités en particulier de ses
forces et d'employés pour le mieux les
enseignants et les locaux qui sont à
leur disposition
ce qui n'a pas toujours été le cas dans
le passé affirme le ministre en tout cas
il leur dit vous ne devez pas déborder
le cadre des moyens dont vous disposez
verrons quelle sera la réaction des
présidents des conseils d'université
toujours en france la chasse à l'homme
déclenchée après le meurtre près de
colmar du maréchal des logis chef des
logis-chef jardot s'est terminée hier
par la mort de lhasa saint émile counord
et cela à peu près au moment même où
face à châlons sur marne se déroulaient
les obsèques du maréchal des logis
jardot les policiers ont été alertés
vers 12h30 par un couple de jeunes gens
qui habitent à 15 kilomètres de colmar
un village a plaidé m
il savait que couderc a été caché dans
une maison de la rue principale de décès
name au numéro 18
car il l'avait vu dans la cour de la
maison et il le connaissait depuis
longtemps car c'était un ancien ami du
père de la jeune fille à 3 heures de
l'après midi
trois gendarmes et trois policiers sous
les ordres d'un capitaine pénétrer dans
la chambre où s'étaient retranchés coup
nairas le gangster a essayé de s'emparer
du pistolet mitrailleur d'un gendarme
une rafale est parti un gendarme et un
inspecteur de police ont été touchés
mais finira lui a reçu une balle dans la
poitrine il a été tué sur le les
policiers ont d'autre part arrêté un
suspect qu'il considère comme le
complice probable de choléra c'est un
nommé alfonso alonso un homme de 55 ans
d'origine portugaise mais pour l'instant
il nie avoir été avec coo nairas lors du
meurtre du maréchal des logis jardin
nous ont parlé d'une affaire policière
et un christian bernadac
vous avez dans votre rubrique littéraire
d'ailleurs un invité qui est aussi un
commissaire de police cet excès le
commissaire khan et je crois qu'ils
viennent nous parler de son dernier
livre éléments parce que pour les
vacances nous avons pensé que deux
en temps nous pouvions aborder les
romans policiers les romans d'espionnage
ou même les romans d'aventuré tout jean
caille vous vous êtes un écrivain
combler vous avez publié convient de
volume de jeu est bien celui que vous
avez entre les mains c'est le sixième le
sixième avec un titre vous voyez à la
mode la drogue de petitjean aux éditions
plon
petitjean c'est un policier petitjean
c'est un agent secret un agent secret
qui qui vous ressemble qui me ressemble
il est un peu plus jeune que moi mais
disons qu'il a mon expérience mais il
qu'il est un homme physiquement plus
beau et plus jeune que moi j'ai relevé
dans lisant votre livre une liste ce
type e et jeu lorsque cette liste a été
terminé je me suis rendu compte que
c'était pratiquement le catalogue de
l'actualité des derniers mois que nous
venons de vivre il y a bien sûr la
drogue marijuana et les fibres et
clandestine il y a le sexe et des orgies
il ya mai 68 et les maoïstes
il y a les détournements d'avion et
évidemment des réseaux d'espionnage et
des réseaux polonais et vous savez qu
hier et avant-hier on a expulsé de
france deux secrétaires dans la salle
polonais alors je voulais vous demander
si vous écrivez votre vos romans
en regardant l'actualité bien goûter
jeux j'aimerais ne pas la créer
l'actualité car à partir de l'instant où
vous relever dans ce roman policier
les titres que vous n'êtes données il
est certain que ce roman est écrit déjà
depuis l'an dernier et je les écris
pendant les vacances
1969 et disant que c'est une espèce de
prémonition est au fond l'histoire est
toujours la même les histoires
policières sont toujours les mêmes
l'histoire d'espionnage sont toujours
les mêmes elle porte toujours sur les
mêmes problèmes et sur les mêmes
personnes un type de personnage car
votre livre commence avec une tuerie qui
ressemble beaucoup à celle de sharon
tête dont nous venons de parler il
jamais arrivé que je m'en suis beaucoup
inspiré effectivement mais qu'est ce qui
peut pousser un policier à écrire des
romans policiers ont pour s on penser
qu'un policier aurait peut-être besoin
d'écrire je ne sais pas des romans
d'amour mais mais vous enfermez rester
toujours dans le même but
qu est-ce que c'est un manque
d'imagination la question n'est pas
méchante la question n'est pas méchante
mail et indiscrètes et indiscrètes parce
que lorsque l'on est jeune et qu'on a
envie d'être policier on a envie de
vivre le métier de policier comme on le
vit au cinéma et puis à partir de
l'instant où il exerce on l'exercé avec
certaines règles imposées par la loi
imposée par les règlements et ce n'est
plus du tout la même chose
mais le policier n'entre pas comme cet
agent secret petitjean dans ce roman par
la fenêtre
ils entrent régulièrement par une porte
officiellement par une bonne et je pense
que je vais pas dans votre poche un
billet de 500 $ ou de 1000 $ hélas non
je vois venir un peu l'actualité à
propos de la drogue
on vient d'arrêter en france on vient de
démanteler un réseau de trafiquants de
drogue
grâce à une agent avait bien une agent
puisque c'était une femme du narcotiques
bureau qui était j'ai fait passer pour
une trafiquante finalement est ce que la
police française emploie ce genre de
méthode est ce qu on fait glisser dans
les réseaux des policiers qui se font
passer eux mêmes pour des truands bien
je crois que l'on pourrait reprocher à
une police qu'elle soit française ou
d'une autre nationalité de ne pas
utiliser les méthodes qui conviennent
pour limiter ce et traquer ces
trafiquants est limitée ce fléau qu'est
la robe le titre de jean caille que les
sergents kayes la drogue de petitjean
aux éditions plon un livre de vacances
merci enfin une nouvelle à mi-chemin de
la politique et de la rubrique
aéronautique la france et l'allemagne de
l'ouest ont décidé d'entreprendre en
commun la fabrication d'un avion-école
ce serait d'ailleurs pas seulement un
agricole il pourrait aussi servir à des
missions tactiques en cas de conflit et
il s'appellera l'alphajet appelé à
remplacer le célèbre fouga magister
l'alphajet a été étudié en commun par
dassault briguer pour la france et
dornier pour l'allemagne
il sera animé par deux réacteurs larzac
dont les prototypes tourne déjà la
snecma et qui donneront à l'avion une
vitesse légèrement inférieur à mach 1
l'excellente visibilité offerte depuis
chacun des deux sièges placés en tandem
destine l'appareil à un ses missions de
colle et d'appui léger tactique
le premier vol pourrait avoir lieu en
mai 1972
la série est prévue à partir de 1967
deux fois plus gros que le plus gros des
avions cargos existant actuellement dans
le monde pesant à pleine charge 346
tonnes le galaxy a fait aujourd'hui sa
première traversée transatlantique
reliant charleston en caroline du sud à
la phase us de rennes m près de
francfort
les ailes de ce mastodonte sont si
grandes et supporter une telle charge
qu'elles sont prévues pour ce cours dès
lors de l'impact
à l'atterrissage sa maniabilité au sol a
été améliorée par le pivotement libre du
train arrière de chaque côté du fuselage
on réduit ainsi le dérapage et l'usure
des pneus l'avion répond ainsi à
l'exigence de pouvoir tourner sur une
piste de 45 mètres de là
long de 75 mètres et une envergure de 67
mètres le plus gros avion du monde se
pilote par est-il aussi facilement que
n'importe quel gros avion de tourisme
il n'y a rien de très particulier à
signaler aujourd'hui dans la rubrique
sportive
et pourtant cet après midi sur votre
écran de la première chaîne vous aurez
peut-être l'occasion d'assister à un
spectacle assez insolite c'est un match
de football féminin entre deux équipes
de france et d'italie
il sera diffusé donc sur la première
chaîne à partir de 17 heures car le
maintenant france vérité nous allons
revenir avec une actualité un peu
vacances puisque vous parlez froid de
croisière fluviale
oui c'est une forme d'évasion qui séduit
de plus en plus les estivants
les croisières fluviales en effet c'est
certainement une solution pour découvrir
la france loin des autoroutes est loin
de la cohue
ce sera l'occasion peut-être si vous
choisissez cette formule pour vos
vacances de découvrir par exemple ce
canal du midi si plein de charme qui
permet de passer de l'atlantique à la
méditerranée
claude dingue c'est ici entre l'éclusé
de l'océan et celle de la méditerranée
au pied du col donneront usq pierre paul
riquet baron de bonrepos trouva la
solution il cherchait en vain depuis
douze ans par sept rigole les eaux de la
montagne noire c'est cool naturellement
vers l'océan et vers la méditerranée
nous sommes ici sur la ligne de partage
les romains avaient déjà songé à relier
toulouse et la garonne à la méditerranée
par voie d'eau en 1666 louis xiv
autorise rites et à construire son canal
en 1680
quinze ans plus tard la voie navigable
était ouverte par soixante cinq écluses
comprenant 103 sas par un souterrain de
150 mètres sous les voûtes du qu'elle
vivait jadis un ermite que les péniches
ravitaillaient au passage par l'escalier
de fonséranes une écluse à cette sas qui
domine béziers par le pont canal sur
l'orb et par agde dont les clues
circulaire à trois portes est unique en
son genre le canal du soleil rejoint la
mer ou presque au phare des ongles luz
il atteint l'étang de thau au loin à une
douzaine de kilomètres le mont
saint-clair 2007
riquet lui ne devait jamais aller jusque
là
mois avant la fin du percement il
s'éteignait ruiné son rêve réalisé n'a
jamais cessé d'être l'une des grandes
préoccupations des populations du sud de
la france n'est pas de génération qui ne
voit ressurgir le projet de canal des
deux mers
et si sur ces chemins de halage ne
passent plus de lure chevaux les étraves
des lourdes gabart motorisés forme
toujours l'eau calme car ce vieux canal
est encore bien vivant son activité
commerciale a progressé au cours des dix
dernières années 2 88% ce et sous la
voûte de ces vieux arbres qui depuis
trois siècles n'ont jamais connu que le
silence lentement les échanges entre
aquitaine et languedoc continue à se
faire parce qu'il avait choisi de
réduire le plus possible les travaux
coûteux de déblais de remblais riquet
devait faire suis façon canal le profil
des côtes
c'est ce tracé qui en épousant la
configuration naturelle du terrain donne
au canal du midi son charme particulier
riquet plantes à des arbres sur et deux
verges pour que même au prix fortes
chaleurs les bateliers leurs chevaux
puissent être à londres
ceci ajouté à l'exceptionnelle beauté
des régions traversées fait du canal du
midi un des hauts lieux touristiques de
la france
depuis plusieurs années déjà dès que le
printemps revient les bateaux de
plaisance y croise les péniches
cherchant à rejoindre plus vite les
rives du levant et par port la nouvelle
où cette s'évader vers le soleil la
corse les baléares ou l'espagne parmi
ceux que nous avons croisés
certains venus d'irlande d'angleterre ou
des pays-bas de la high line est un art
nouveau de vacances
la croisière fluviale monsieur adolphe
directeur d'une compagnie de location de
bateaux nous parle de son organisation
vous avez combien de bateaux il a vendu
ce bateau de quatre classes il ya un
petit de 55 ans est le plus grand onze
mètres 4 g ce sont des bateaux qui
peuvent être occupés par combien de
personnes alors le clip dix ans pour 4
5% et les plus grands s'en faut sept à
huit personnes et vous croisiez re des
buts où il commence à toulouse c'est pas
les gars bordeaux jusqu'à 400 d'or ou
encore les deux stats ou pour l'annual
pas cassano d'erika 102e vous avez tout
ce qu'il faut avec vous pour faire la
cuisine
pour passer vos vacances tout seul vous
bateaux sont entièrement équipés tout
équipé avec le végal les pédales la
weser les couvertures du gaz et figo
l'eau chauffe roi a tout ce qu'il faut
on peut un peu le helley les équipements
supplémentaires comme les visiteurs tous
les cas nos spots ya la navigation sur
le canal du midi et elle assujettis à
des paiements de taxes pour passer les
écluses par exemple non il n'existe pas
des voies navigables intérieures sont
comme les les routes nationales son
public depuis le krach de napoléon je
crois pour naviguer sur ce canal
il suffit de venir chez vous si on n'a
pas un bateau personnellement de vous
verser la somme d'argent nécessaire et
partir à la barre de son de son bateau
oui mais pour les résidents en france
poté les français y prend une
s'inquiéter car la capacité soit à la
mer soit les banques ailleurs et pour ça
on peut s'adresser au tour de france
n'ont cru qu'elle vit en france pour
passer le permis
autrement dit faut avoir soit le permis
mer soit le permis rivière exactement
mais le permis rivière suffit pour le
canal du midi
oui et si on a l'intention de naviguer
un petit peu dans l'étang de thau a le
même terme ici parce que cette voix
intérieure
on peut aller sur un coteau
jusqu'au cercle s'est enlevée alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour réserver
avait touché vous commettez 20 partout
chez nous il faut réserver beaucoup en
avant ce prix de noël parce que la
compacte nos clients sont anglais et ont
fait parler leurs vacances beaucoup sont
en avance de notre saison commence à
partir du 23 mars et jusqu'au le 15
novembre
et maintenant si le coeur vous en dit
et bien c'est sur ces images apaisantes
que nous conclurons ce journal au revoir
merci